Alex here with the game spot news update
the latest humble bundle is all about 2k
games and you can pay what you want for
critically acclaimed games such as
BioShock Infinite and spec ups align
Humble Bundle allows you to pay whatever
you want although there is a one dollar
minimum for steam keys and you can
choose how your money is distributed
between the Humble Bundle organization
2k games and American Red Cross and
action against hunger with any purchase
you get the original BioShock XCOM
declassified and the darkness too if you
pay more than the average payment of 529
you get bioshock 2 mafia tube and spec
ops the line if you pony up more than
twenty dollars you get xcom enemy
Unknown and bioshock infinite if you're
feeling guilty because you spend too
much during the steam summer sale you
can ease your conscience by donating to
charity and get some more games while
you at it the deal will be running until
july twenty seconds so make sure you
grab some games you want and support a
good cause i'd spend 529 on spike up
still line alone so you should totally
check out this humble bundle keep it
locked to gamespot com for all your
video game news I'd pay 550 for the for
the dough baths back up a lot